OSHISON.
TOM WILSON RUMBLES BACK TOWARDS
THE POINT.
FEED FOR AN OVECHKIN PASS,
CARL
PLAY.
LOOK AT THE DECEPTIONCEPTION,
OVECHKIN TO CARLSON, AND ON THE
DOOR STEP.
SKATING OUT OF HIS ZONE,
PASSING THE PUCK SHOWED SOME PR
SLICK HANDS.
>> IT'S 1-1. HERE
IS OLIVIAY, GETS A STEP ON
CARLSON AND TRIES TO STUFF I IT.
IT'S FORSBERG ANGLING THE OTHER
IN BLUE TONIGHT.
THE CAPITALS TWO HAGELIN.
HAGELIN FROM THE ANGLE,  ASSIST
WILL HAGELIN. IN.
SOME SHOTS FROM BEHIND.
THERE TVR  POINTS.
HE IS A STUD DEFENSEMAN,
ST BE IN TO THE NET.
NO ONE PICKING HIM UP
WHATSOEVER, AND THE PUCK IS IN
THE BACK O
>> Joe: DEFLECTION, SCORE!
THREE ALL.
>> Craig: REACHING IN, LOOKED LE
FORSBERG GOT A PIECE OF IT, AND
PUT IT BETWEEN THEORLOV.
HAGELIN KEEPS IT ALIVE.
CENTERING
TO LET IT GO AWAY, WITH DUCHENE
TRYING ON SAROS FOORSBERG, MAKE
MOVE.
THERE BY "KUZIE," TRYING THAT
LATERAL PA IN THE
SECOND.
1:08 ON THE POWER PLAY FOR
BACKSTROM.
ADVANCING WITH KUZNETSOV.
HE IT TOWARDS THE NET.
IT'S THE STICK IN THE RIGHT WAS
THE NET.
HERE IT IS.
NOW HE STEPS O BACK BY DOWD.
AROUND FOR CARLSON.
IT AND ITS